chapter fab the corpse
get in that correct [ __ ] get in that
[ __ ] garage you a little stupid [ __ ]
I can't just get out of there
I can't
okay
take the cavalry ow
[Music]
okay great this so annoying oh sorry
it's not lat
that one's locked
that one's locked it's a hospital so we
were like in there right
imagine test how am I done hey they in
there
the whole entire cabinets gotta get a
half dirty calendar
Monday May 17th a la mrs. Carlton
hello massage doesn't let me just check
this room Oh quick nametag hobby deck a
mess
[Music]
[Music]
to unlock
[Music]
here we go Wow oh wow how does a guy
with a cave right here how about that
hey miss thank you got a guy right there
tire on that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
know so that's up but I think I'm
probably open up that stuff now get that
get those guys you know
[Music]
those two a moans ka nirmaan here damn
up in your eyes my star yeah now nice
why am i and why people always think
they can enter a bell and and just get
everything they want
and I can't access yeah yeah I got that
K I just made your having a like I said
that Machop their chapters quick here
out on the road don't you want it sir
same moon same night sky mmm good after
an hour of driving it's easy to forget
all about that dead world back there and
that's how I say but okay would have
survived though if you came from the
future how did he not die along with
everybody else
oh yeah just saw his body in the morgue
oh that was a time traveler well I'm
[ __ ] Jesus work do you just leave a
copy of yourself every time you use the
box is that it are there copies of me
all over the place so I'm going to his
house speak to him he's not there what
if I changed something and he's not
alive at all sex s sake Anna maybe all
of this has been completely pointless
maybe there's nothing I can do after all
Beibei maybe these will be my last days
along with everybody else's okay well
the thought ties my stomach in knots
yeah chase that no I better just not
think about it and carry on yes yes all
right having enough gas that's the end
of that chapter I guess I brought enough
gas